está delante,
pero la atención encubierta
está permanentemente sondeando los alrededores,
sin que uno apunte la mirada hacia allí.
Soy neurocientífico computacional,
y trabajo en interfaces cognitivas cerebro-máquina,
es decir que reúno el cerebro y la computadora.
Me encantan los patrones cerebrales.
Los patrones cerebrales son importantes para nosotros
porque mediante ellos podemos crear modelos para las computadoras,
y en base en esos modelos,
las computadoras pueden reconocer cuán bien funciona nuestro cerebro.
Y si no funciona bien,
estas computadoras pueden servir como dispositivos de apoyo
para terapias.
Pero eso también implica algo,
porque elegir patrones incorrectos
genera modelos incorrectos
y por ende terapias incorrectas.
¿Cierto?
En el caso de la atención,
el hecho de que no solo
los ojos pueden desviar la atención,
sino que nuestro pensamiento, también puede desviarla,
hace de la atención encubierta un modelo computacional interesante.
Y yo quería saber cuáles eran los patrones cerebrales
cuando uno mira abiertamente o cuando lo hace de manera encubierta.
Diseñé un experimento.
En ese experimento hay dos cuadrados que parpadean,
uno que parpadea a un ritmo más lento que el otro.
Dependiendo de a qué cuadrado uno preste atención,
ciertas partes del cerebro resonarán al mismo ritmo
que la tasa de parpadeo.
Por eso, analizando las señales cerebrales,
podemos seguir exactamente hacia dónde miramos
o a qué prestamos atención.
Para ver qué ocurre en el cerebro cuando uno presta atención abierta,
pedí a unas personas que miraran directamente uno de los cuadrados
y que prestaran atención.
En este caso, no sorprende ver que estos cuadrados parpadeantes
aparecen en las señales cerebrales
provenientes de la parte posterior de la cabeza,
que es la responsable del procesamiento de la información visual.
Pero me interesaba mucho
ver qué ocurría en el cerebro si uno prestaba atención encubierta.
Esta vez pedí a algunas personas que miraran el centro de la pantalla
y, sin mover sus ojos,
que prestaran atención a cualquiera de estos cuadrados.
Al hacerlo,
vimos que ambas tasas de parpadeo aparecían en sus señales cerebrales,
pero, es interesante,
solo una de ellas, la que recibía la atención,
tenía señales más fuertes,
por lo que había algo en el cerebro
que manejaba esta información
y ese algo era básicamente la activación del área frontal.
La parte frontal del cerebro es la responsable
de las funciones cognitivas superiores que tenemos como humanos.
La parte frontal, parece que trabaja como filtro
tratando de dejar pasar solo la información del parpadeo correcto
al que uno le presta atención
y trata de inhibir la información procedente del cuadro ignorado.
La capacidad de filtrar que tiene el cerebro es clave para la atención,
pero es algo ausente en algunas personas;
por ejemplo, en personas que tienen TDAH.
Una persona que tiene TDAH no puede inhibir estas distracciones,
y por eso no puede centrarse en una tarea durante mucho tiempo.
Pero ¿y si esta persona
pudiera jugar un videojuego específico
con su cerebro conectado a la computadora,
y así entrenar su propio cerebro
para inhibir estas distracciones?
Bueno, el TDAH es solo un ejemplo.
Podemos usar estas interfaces cognitivas cerebro-máquina
en muchos otros campos cognitivos.
Hace solo unos años,
mi abuelo tuvo un derrame cerebral, y perdió el habla.
Podía entender a todos, pero no podía responder,
ni siquiera por escrito, porque era analfabeto.
Así que falleció en silencio.
En ese momento, recuerdo haber pensado:
¿Y si hubiera una computadora
que pudiese hablar por él?
Ahora, tras años de estar en este campo,
puedo ver que esto puede ser posible.
Imaginen si pudiéramos encontrar patrones cerebrales
cuando la gente piensa en imágenes o incluso en letras,
como que la letra A genere un patrón cerebral diferente
que la letra B, etc.
¿Podría algún día una persona que no habla comunicarse con una computadora?
¿Y si una computadora pudiera
ayudar a entender los pensamientos de una persona que está en coma?
Todavía no lo logramos,
pero presten mucha atención.
Lo lograremos pronto.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)